Today I'm talking about
exploratory spatial data
analysis.
To start, let's
talk about exploratory data
analysis.
I'm sure most of you
are familiar with it,
but good to recap.
So exploratory data
analysis or EDA
is an approach slash philosophy
for data analysis
that employs a variety
of techniques,
mostly graphical to, one, maximize
insight into a data set,
cover underlying structure,
extract variables,
detect outliers and anomalies.
So one paper, for
example, described
EDA tend to discover
potentially explicable patterns.
So EDA, as we might know, has an
emphasis on data visualization,
a use of descriptive
statistics, and it really
emphasizes on discovering
outliers in your data set.
So here are two wonderful
graphics from the Tidy Tuesday.
This is how I'm guessing most
of us are familiar with EDA
itself.
So exploratory
spatial data analysis
takes these same concepts and
applies to the spatial data.
So to understand
that, we have to start
with the first law of geography,
which states that everything
is related to everything
else, but near things
are more related
than distant things.
So in essence, ESDA extends
exploratory data analysis
to spatial relationships.
It asks questions
like, are things
randomly distributed in space?
Are there spatial outliers?
Are close things more
similar than things
that are further away?
So where EDA compares
a part to the whole, ESDA
compares a part to
its neighboring parts.
So in ESDA or exploratory
spatial data analysis
where evaluate a location
relative to its neighboring
location, not the
whole or group.
Right so I learned exploratory
spatial data analysis
in grad school, and I learned
it through Python and libraries
like geopandas, shapely and
pysal. But it was Python
and I really wanted
to use rstats.
So around 2021, I wanted
to get back into this
and I discovered the
R package spdep.
So it's the package for
spatial dependence, weighting
and statistics.
So some things about spdep, it
was first released in 2002
and it was initially designed
for sp objects, which
is like the first way to
interact with spatial data in R.
I'm not sure if any of you
have used, it interesting.
And it covers most of
the spatial econometrics.
So statistics, weights,
neighbors and things like that.
But in 2002, I was
6 and I essentially
grew up with the tidyverse.
So when I use spdep,
I have this a little bit
of a perceived
paradigm gap where
the way that spdep functions
is different than the way I
think about R.
So naturally, when I
couldn't make a neighbor
list in a mutate function
call, I created an issue.
And unfortunately that
issue went nowhere.
So my response was to create
a tidy interface called sfdep.
So sfdep is an
interface and extension
to spdep for
spatial dependence.
And some principles
are that I always want
to use SF objects for geometry.
That's what I'm familiar with,
and most people might be. Always
return dplyr-friendly objects.
So lists, data frames,
vectors and then, additionally,
functionality shouldn't
be dependent upon dplyr
for those who don't want dplyr.
And then additionally,
all functionality
that I've, additional
functionality,
is implemented
using spdep object
for backwards compatibility.
And then so fundamentally
with exploratory spatial data
analysis, we need to
understand our neighbors.
And to do that, we will use the
st contiguity function which
takes an SF C-class object or
the geometry column of an SF
object and returns a list for
identifying your neighbors.
Here's an example of that
using dplyr-friendly code.
And the result is a list
with where each element is
an integer vector, and
the elements contain
row positions of its neighbors.
And we're not just limited
to identifying contiguity
for polygons.
We can implement finding
K-nearest neighbors, distance
bands, so on and so forth.
And additionally, if you
want to use spatial weights,
we just pass in
the neighbor object
the spatial weights and we get
row standardized by default.
So here's an example
of doing all that
in one call with mutate.
Again, we're not
just limited to that.
So let's compare the syntax.
So here's a map of
comparing clusters of crime
in 1830s France.
Here's the code
for using spdep
was no pipe operator
and lots of assignments.
Here's the same result using
sfdep. One assignment and two
pipe operators.
So here's the same map, same
different code, same results.
So sfdep doesn't just
act as an interface,
it extends it as well.
So we can do local join counts.
The first open source
implementation of co-location
quotients. It also
implements ESRI's
Emerging Hot Spot Analysis.
It also integrates
with sfnetworks.
So what's next?
User validation.
Ensure parity with Python and
then make a hex logo one day.
So give it a star
and give it a go.